donnez
le duplex d'un journaliste de cnn à
propos à des frappes de missiles à lviv
dans l'ouest de l'ukraine il ya trois
jours laisse certains internautes
sceptiques effectivement ce duplex de
voix si c'est celui de john lemond
l'envoyé spécial de cnn l'un des envoyés
spéciaux de cnn en ukraine on né le 26
mars il couvre une frappe de missiles
russes sur un dépôt de carburant près de
lviv dans l'ouest une attaque vous voyez
qui a provoqué un gigantesque incendie
et un détail a retenu l'attention de
plusieurs internautes regardent et c'est
cette inscription edmonton sur l'inde et
uniforme de pompier edmonton c'est la
capitale de l'état de l'alberta au
canada c'est que tout est étrange
lorsqu'il s'agit d'évoquer la guerre en
ukraine mais pour certains internautes
et bien la réponse c'est la raison
surtout est toute trouvée la scène
n'aurait donc pas lieu en ukraine mais à
edmonton au canada donc selon eux cnn
qui seraient pris vous le voyez en
flagrant délit de fake news de
désinformation donc et de falsification
cette théorie elle va être prise sur
plusieurs publications que ce soit sur
tik tok facebook ou encore ici on voit
ce post trade it qui a été archivée avec
cette question qui forcément c'est mlle
trouver ce qu'il y a en edmonton en
ukraine et non de ces publications vont
pour prendre prendre comme base ce tweet
qui vous le voyez indique le mot ukraine
entre guillemets pour sous-entendre donc
la vidéo est truqué un verdict lu et
bien non elle n'est pas truquée de cette
scène elle se déroule effectivement à
lviv en ukraine le site de stockage que
l'on voit ici dans le duplex on le
retrouve injustement sur sur google
street view grâce à la géolocalisation
et ce site il a bien été ciblés par des
frappes prusse il ya trois jours mais si
le mot edmonton apparaît sur l'un des
uniformes et bien c'est pour la simple
et bonne raison cette raison qui nous
est d'ailleurs expliquée par ce
journaliste de cnn tout simplement parce
que ces uniformes ont été donnés par des
pompiers canadiens à leurs confrères
ukrainien et d'ailleurs ça ne date pas
de la date de la guerre en ukraine
puisque cet article du média canadien
siby si pardon évoquait déjà ses dons en
2017 dans cet article pourquoi parce que
les pompiers denton effectivement livres
du matériel à ceux de livres depuis 2015
via cette ong celle de kevin wale fire
fighters aide l'ukraine qui est basé à
edmonton ceci explique cela le lot angie
qui se réjouissait d'ailleurs dans un
tweet dans un facebook récent que
justement les pompiers craignent un
puisse porter les uniformes des naunton
et qui d'ailleurs sur les réseaux
sociaux toujours en l'occurrence
facebook accentué bien sur le fait qu'il
n'y avait pas de complot qui appelait
aussi aux dons de bottes ou de casques
de matériel et qu'ils partageaient donc
ces images par exemple où l'on voit
justement l'uniforme en question ce sont
des images ici de 2017 sur instagram une
autre vidéo bombardements interpellé un
internaute qui nous demande de vérifier
sa véracité effectivement c'est un
abonné du compte twitter info ou intox
f24 qui nous a alertés sur ce contenu on
va le voir ensemble regarder c'est ce
bombardement ccc effondrement pardon
deux bâtiments qui s'effondra l'un après
l'autre on voit que quelqu'un prend en
photo elle assène cette vidéo est là et
et virales mais essentiellement en arabe
il faut le dire on voit ici par exemple
la capture d'écran facebook qui date du
18 mars et on nous explique ce serait le
bombardement par l'armée russe du
ministère ukrainien de la défense et
bien qu en est il la recherche d'image
inversée elle nous donne la réponse on
retrouve exactement la même vidéo dans
plusieurs médias on né le 12 mai 2021 la
guerre en ukraine n'avait pas commencé
et ses images ce sont celles est
d'ailleurs son nom apparaît ici du
journaliste de la fp omar elle sert ça
oui on va les voir ensemble ces images
ce sont celles de la destruction de
l'immeuble alchourouk à gaza tour
d'application où se trouvait aussi le
bureau de la chaîne de télévision al
aqsa chaîne palestinienne fondée par
leur âme à ce qu'on découvre à les
images
qui diffuse depuis la bande de gaza qui
a été visée on le rappelle par des
frappes israéliennes en représailles à
des roquettes du hamas ces frappes qui
ont été qualifiés quelques mois plus
tard en juillet par human rights autres
comme violant les lois la guerre donc si
comme cet internaute vous avez une image
qui vous interpellent si vous interrogez
sur son contexte ou encore ça son
authenticité bien la direction twitter
pour nous envoyer un message sur le
compte info intox f24 merci anthony info
intox avec anthony st léger rester avec
nous dans cinq minutes un nouveau
journal sur france 24
[Musique]